الحب لا يعرف عمرا مقوله شهيره نسمعها
كثيرا لكن يبدو ان العلم لا يتفق معها
اعاده دراسه حديثه اجرتها جامعه هيموري
الامريكيه اثبتت علميا ان العلاقات التي
تتخللها بعض الفجوات العمريه هي اكثرها
تعرضا لنهايات غير سعيده بالفعل بحسب هذه
الدراسه فانه كلما زاد الفارس السن زادت
احتمالات الانفصال بين الزوجين فالازواج
الذين لديهم فارق في السنب نحو خمس سنوات
اكثر عرضه بنسبه
18% للانفصال من المثير للاهتمام ان هذا
الرقم ارتفع الى 39% للازواج الذين لديهم
فرق في السن يبلغ 10 سنوات و95% بالنسبه
الى اولئك الذين لديهم فرق في السن يبلغ
20 سنه الباحثون يرون مشاهدينا ان
السيناريو المثالي يكمن في سارق عمري لا
يزيد على سنه واحده بين الزوجين مما يقلل
من احتمال الانفصال الى 3% فقط
[موسيقى]
خلينا نحكي من ناحيه نفسيه اسريه اجتماعيه
هل هذه الدراسه يمكن ناخذها على محمل
الجذب بانه مش لازم يكون في فرق او الاامن
علشان استمراريه الزواج يكون في فرق سنه
لا اكثر او لا خلينا نحكي عن هاي الدراسه
وعن فكره الاهم كمان مشان نفهمها السؤال
الاهم هل يا ترى فقط هو الحب السبب لانه
نحن نختار شريك الحياه لا اكيد لا صح فشو
اللي بيصير باغلب الحالات نحن لما الرجل
بروح بيختار زوج اكبر كثير منه بالعمر
بيكون في وراها اسباب الها علاقه بامور
يعني هو بطفولته في انعكاسات نفسيه
واحيانا نتفاجا لما نشوف اشخاص منقول كيف
عشرين سنه وفي اشخاص مشاهير وعلى مستوى
حتى سياسي احيانا بنقول زوجته بتكبره
بخمسه وعشرين سنه ففي خلفيه نفسيه الاحيان
اللي بتختار رجل اكبر
يمكن ايضا في هذه الدراسات نفسيه صحيح
وهاي الفكره هاي الدراسه اكدتها انه كل
الفتاه اللواتي كانوا علاقتهم مع وال
علاقه سويه يعني هي عندها مشاعر غير
متوازنه معه بتروح بتختار دائما شريك
بالعمر بيمثل له الصوره اللي هي مخفيه
عندها باللاوعي عن صوره الاب ولكن للاسف
دائما اختياراتهم غلط لانه نحن بنعرف الزق
شو الفكره اللي بيكون عندهم هاي المشكله
ليه لانه نحن بنعرف لما انا بدي اختار
شريك انا ما بدي اياه يكون صوره عن حدا هو
المفروض يكون بكملني يكون في مشاعر بيني
وبينه يكون انا وياه منسجمين بالحياه هو
ما رح يكمل صوره ابغى او ام غير متواجده
او شخص عنيف او شخص ظلمني فبالتالي هاي
الزواجات اللي بيكون منشاها النفسي غير
سويه بتكون محكومه بالانفصال وبعد فتره
بتقول بانه هل انا لو رجع في الزمن انا
بسالها سؤال لو انا اعطيتك اليوم الخيار
ورجع الزمن هل تختاري بتقول
فهي الزواجات اللي هي فارق العمر منها له
اسباب نفسيه ممكن ياثر هاي من جهه من جهه
ثانيه جهه ثانيه فارغ العمر كيف بياثر
اللي هو
نكنه انا بالنسبه الي بيحكي عن حالي قبل
عشر سنين كان عندي كثير علاقات اجتماعيه
كنت انسانه بحب الزحمه والضجيج هلا خلاص
40 فبالنسبه
احتراف صغيره فهلا بيصير كيف الموضوع بصير
فلتره علاقات اجتماعيه مكان اقرب الى
الهدوء هذا هو اللي بيصير بانه لما يكون
هالفارق في شخص وصل لهالمكان في شخص نفسه
في عالم اخر
[موسيقى]